good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson saying happy Friday in your head
you always imagine the revolution when
it starts we'll start with tanks and
gunfire with chaos and soldiers in the
street you'll know when it comes
but it never does instead the really big
changes to American Life the profound
ones that affect all of us forever those
changes almost always begin quietly with
gentle pleas for tolerance
we'd like to do things a little
differently they tell you we'd like to
make a change to some customer belief
that people have been attached to for
the last few thousand years but don't be
alarmed it's not a big deal you don't
even need to participate all we ask is
that you let us live the way we want to
live
that's always the pitch and of course
you always agree to it why wouldn't you
who could say no to that some guy down
the street wants to wear a dress okay
fine have a party it doesn't affect you
you don't have to wear a dress so go
ahead Live and Let Live
but it turns out that's never actually
the deal
the guy down the street wears his dress
but after a while that's not enough for
him he's still angry and for some reason
he's angry with you and that doesn't
make sense because you're the person
with no problem with him wearing a dress
in the first place what did you do wrong
well the problem is you're not wearing a
dress and neither are your kids your
normal person clothes the ones you've
always worn are suddenly immoral you've
got to change immediately
whoa wait a second you say that's not
what we agreed to you do your thing and
I'll do mine remember
they don't remember they don't care
that's not how it works you don't get to
do your thing anymore the dress guy's in
charge now everybody's got to do his
thing the dress thing or face punishment
that's how it goes be tolerant becomes
show some respect which evolves very
quickly into bow down before us and lick
our feet or else we'll hurt you
that's the final stage that's where we
are now
for example a democratic lawmaker in
Virginia called Elizabeth Guzman is
introducing a bill that will charge
parents with a felony strip them of
their employment and imprison them if
they don't wholeheartedly endorse their
minor children's sex changes
so your 12 year old daughter says she
wants a mastectomy
if you object to that in any way
if you raise questions
Elizabeth Guzman will send you to jail
for real here's a local news report
her bill would expand the state's
definition of child abuse and neglect to
include parents who do not affirm their
child's gender identity or sexual
orientation there's an investigation
also in place that is not only you know
from a social worker but there is also a
police investigation before we make the
decision that there is going to be a CPS
charge what could the penalties be if
you know the investigation concludes and
it's concluded that a parent is not
affirming of their lgbtq child what
could the consequences be well we first
have to have an investigation you know
it could be a felony it could be a
misdemeanor but we know that CPS charge
could harm you know your employment
could harm your education
so who is this Elizabeth Guzman
well Elizabeth Guzman came to this
country not so long ago from Peru as a
single mother
now rather than wait a while maybe spend
a few Generations here before telling
you how to raise your children in
America she's decided to get right to it
and completely change child rearing in
this country in a way that would never
be tolerated for a second in the country
from which she comes try that in the
Andes honey and see how that works yeah
but in this country according to
Elizabeth Guzman you have to affirm your
child's sex change or else you're going
to prison and the state will raise your
kids
and you got to think maybe they've
wanted this for a while what would this
mean well it would mean fewer intact
families it would mean people like
Elizabeth Guzman make the decisions the
meaningful decisions within your house
it means less resistance from you it
means more powerful them
what it doesn't mean is that Elizabeth
Guzman will be protecting your kids she
doesn't even claim this law will protect
your kids instead she acknowledges the
whole point is to quote educate parents
right so like the coveted vaccine this
is a pretty easy way to figure out who's
on which side are you for this okay
you're on our team
you're willing to surrender control of
your own children to Elizabeth Guzman
who again just got here
but if you're not for it then we know
you're not on our team We Know Who You
Are
we can silence you we can punish you
because you refuse to be educated
so it's a signaling mechanism and you
know that because the ideology that
underlies it gender ideology is
completely incoherent it doesn't make
any sense at all it is not rooted in
science it's a form of religion that's
so crazy it dares you to say something
about it what you can't even say that if
you do they know you're on the other
side
and it's not just lunatics and audio
logs like Elizabeth Guzman from Peru
it's doctors it's medical professionals
here's a video from Boston Children's
Hospital one of the most famous
hospitals in the world which like many
hospitals in the United States at this
point under the Joe Biden Administration
cuts the breasts off of minor girls
for no medically justifiable reason
watch a practicing psychologist now
attending psychologist at Boston
Children's Hospital explain how early
children can become trans
so most of the patients that we have in
the gems Clinic actually know their
gender usually around the age of puberty
but a good portion of children do know
as early as seemingly from the womb and
they will usually Express their gender
identity as very young children some as
soon as they can talk they might say
phrases such as I'm a girl or I'm a boy
or I'm going to be a woman or I'm going
to be a mom kids know very very early so
in the gems Clinic we see a variety of
young children all the way down to ages
two and three and usually up to the ages
of nine
so that's Carrie McGregor she's a
psychologist she works at Harvard I
wonder how many children does Carrie
McGregor have she raised a lot of kids
does she watched kids carefully does she
know anything about kids
because she's telling you if your little
kid says all right maybe I'm the other
sex that means your kid is the other sex
well that's insane because almost 100
percent of kids at one point or another
at a certain point in development say
things like I think I'm a boy I think
I'm a girl
and you smile indulgently
get back to me in 15 years
but no this is Carrie McGregor in the
womb you can know so think about
what they're telling you they're telling
you the developing child in the womb is
just a part of the mother therefore you
can abort that child at any time it's
like an appendectomy but at the same
time that same cluster of cells that
fetus can also be woke
and ascribe to left liberal gender
ideology and you need to honor that
so no sane person could believe any of
this voluntarily it doesn't even make
sense on its face again it's a religion
and if you resist it they Resort
immediately to force no questions
allowed again this is science and the
essence of science is Relentless
questioning about what you think you
know is true that is the scientific
method that science itself
but it's no longer allowed the American
Medical Association which is utterly
becloud itself along with the American
Academy of Pediatrics and the Children's
Hospital Association just sent a letter
to the Attorney General of the United
States demanding that the bite
Administration and we're quoting takes
Swift action to investigate and
prosecute high-profile users on social
media who have engaged in quote
disinformation
you hate to always invoke the German
government
of 80 years ago but what else is that
that's totalitarian they're saying if
you disagree with what we're doing
people with guns should come and take
you away
now you'd think someone in the media
would point out wow you know we can't
have that in the United States where
people are free to believe what they
want and to talk about it in public and
to ask questions in fact they should be
encouraged to but the media don't say
anything like that
they're joining with the Children's
Hospital Association the AMA to call for
more censorship at gunpoint watch
obviously the question becomes then when
misinformation disinformation is being
spread when hate and threats are being
spread where are the social media
companies what's YouTube doing what's
Twitter doing and of course then you
have the reaction to that oh this is big
Tech silencing people it always becomes
a debate about Free Speech doesn't it
yeah it does you know last week Twitter
suspended lives of tick tock um
specifically for the policy against the
promotion of threats uh violence and
harassment so great job right
um but it's been seven days and Libs of
tick tock is back now and they're
tweeting right this very minute this is
violence this is harassment it's clear
what these accounts are doing
Freddie back to the point at the open
when the revolution comes there won't be
tanks and soldiers won't be Storm
Troopers no uniforms and symbols it'll
be some unmarried 30 year old woman
talking in a sing-songi voice inflection
at the end right right
with for special glasses or complex
classes that don't actually improve her
vision
she'll have all kinds of pointless
Humanities degrees and she'll be on
cable news saying right it's violent so
what she's really saying is
shut up and Obey or will hurt you
she's delivering the same message that
these Stormtrooper delivers but she's
doing it in a sing-songy way this
disinformation call it's literal but
this is the opposite of disinformation
it's not disinformation this is
literally what they're saying Boston
Children's Hospitals we just showed you
on tape is telling you what they're
doing they perform double mastectomies
on minors for no medical reason
whatsoever
that's insane it ought to be a crime in
a civilized country it would be and they
know that because when they were caught
they tried to erase the evidence and
they're not alone
UCSF UW Health in Wisconsin golisano
children's hospital New York Vanderbilt
Health children's Minnesota all of these
hospitals have deleted the evidence of
their gender affirming procedures their
grotesque mutilation of children after
they were publicized their own words
were publicized online no one's twisting
it people are just putting up their
words
and not all the videos have been deleted
Planned Parenthood is big into this now
because it's lucrative so here's Planned
Parenthood in 2021 telling children that
so-called puberty blockers are harmless
right that's a lie and by the way
there's no such thing as a puberty
blocker
these drugs are hormone argonests and
they're FDA approved for things like
cancer treatment you get prostate cancer
and they lower your testosterone for
example to prevent the cancer from
growing quickly they are not approved
for so-called puberty blocking
they're unapproved and the long-term
effects are not known but it's pretty
obvious they're Grim but Planned
Parenthood won't tell you that here's
their video
your transgender or non-binary you may
find that your puberty experiences don't
line up with your gender identity or how
you see yourself that feeling can be
uncomfortable scary and stressful if
that sounds like you know that you're
not alone
there are medicines you can take to
delay puberty for a while they're called
puberty blockers and they work like a
stop sign by halting the hormones
testosterone and estrogen that cause
puberty changes like facial hair growth
and periods puberty blockers are safe
and can give you more time to figure out
what feels right for you your body and
your gender identity
okay everything about that is dark and
horrifying and there should be an
uprising against that that's aimed at
your children not at adults who can make
rational decisions but children people
too young to drive or drink alcohol or
smoke cigarettes or serve in the
military or vote people who are not we
have agreed as a group capable of making
rational adult decisions and that's
aimed at them it's propaganda aimed at
them and it's a lie
Purity blockers are safe they are
absolutely not safe you can't delay
puberty without damaging severely the
bodies of young children
the FDA just identified several quote
clinically serious cases of side effects
after these drugs were recklessly
administered to children by lunatic
ideologues the FDA found a quote
plausible association between the use of
puberty blockers and something called
intracranial hypertension you want that
for your 13 year old
according to the Mayo Clinic that
condition can cause brain swelling
double vision severe headaches permanent
vision loss known as brain damage
brain damage oh great okay on top of
that the European Journal of
Endocrinology among many other
Publications has found that so-called
Purity blockers often cause quote
decreased bone density which is
associated with a high risk of
osteoporosis
and there are other permanent side
effects as well we don't even know the
scope of them because this has never
been tested longitudinally ever
but the effects are very obvious and if
you poke around on the internet for
about four minutes you will see them one
teenage girl just uploaded a video
showing the effects of five years of
puberty blockers on her watch this
when I talk about being too far gone not
I don't really know what else to call it
um this is what I mean this is how deep
my voice is
um it's gotten deeper over time and it's
settled
um this is what I mean by hair loss and
it just keeps getting worse it keeps
thinning it keeps receding backwards
you know and I'm not exactly sure that's
coming back
um those are the main things when I talk
about being androgenized
um to a point of no return this is what
happens when you give a woman
testosterone this is for five years this
is what happens
yeah that's what happens that and a lot
of other things that's what they're
telling you is gender affirming no it's
mutilation it's grotesque it's
destroying people's lives children's
lives we made a documentary on this for
Tucker Carlson original so we spoke to a
lot of people who had endured similar
torture
the testosterone kind of had this effect
on me where with every step that I took
it would feel good for a short amount of
time but then eventually it's like those
same feelings come back up there's the
initial Euphoria did you go through I
changed my gender and everything's going
to be wonderful it was euphoric I I was
like the feeling I had when I started
Living as a man was I I was free I was
finally who I should have been all along
but that Euphoria was short-lived my
mental health just got worse my ability
to socialize just got worse I felt so
disconnected from myself I started using
like drugs and alcohol as a crutch and I
was just a total disaster and the the
effects of the testosterone on my mental
health
specifically just made everything 10
million times worse I had blood into the
LIE
you almost took my
took me out it's just awful and every
person is participating in this in their
moments of clarity knows that 10 years
from now there will be thousands of
vocal victims of this moment of true
craziness and hysteria that has gripped
our country people's lives are being
destroyed right before us most adults
are too cowardly to say a word about it
and the Democratic party is actively
doing all it can to promote this to
protect hospitals that are mutilating
and destroying the lives of children in
the state of California always a
Bellwether a legislator called Scott
weiner has just sponsored legislation to
make California a so-called Sanctuary
state for kids who want to mutilate
their own bodies to castrate themselves
Scott weiner really is he a good father
would you trust this guy within 500
yards of a child probably not
Kevin Newsome just signed the bill of
course
so what's the point here it's certainly
not to protect children it's not
protecting them any parent will tell you
if you want to protect children you tell
them take a deep breath and reach
adulthood and then make rational
decisions about how to live their lives
you would definitely not let them make a
decision an irreversible decision like
this for themselves you're their parent
that's the whole point
but the Democratic party doesn't like
parents the Democratic party is
replacing parents with itself we're in
charge now
it's the most recognizable possible move
for any totalitarian movement break up
the family replace parents with
politicians the state is in charge the
party is in charge
obviously and it's happening all over
the country subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight